let's go back to saturday um
what were you guys doing when you
realized you know
the search is on for you guys we all
started friday we we left
friday we were driving to utah and we
left around 12.
i'm on five i called my brother juan
montes to let him know where i was at
five o'clock friday friday and i let him
know where we're at
and i told him that we're gonna go up to
the hills we talked about some other
stuff
and i might not have reception i had he
wanted to come out there too so i told
him if anything just leave me a message
and as soon as i get service i'll i'll
call you
the next day well we got there we set up
the campground we did all that stuff we
hate kids
running around but at the campground we
don't have service because you're in the
middle of nowhere
the next day we went out for a trail
ride
with the atvs we went out for a trail
ride and i was able to get signal that's
when i read
you wanted for murder for my son and my
son was in the back seat of the razor
and i kidnapped my other son in montes
and he was right next to me he was
actually reading the message too
so when all this happened we pulled over
after like an hour into the trail we
pulled over
and i called his mother carina cisneros
we call her mother and letter
no carina is the eight-year-old there's
two kids involved there's an
eight-year-old
and then there's a 12 year old that's
eden he's a 12
and the eight is daniel so we call it
the most
one that i killed the eight-year-old and
we told him
you know what he's with us everything's
okay she asked questions to daniel
um did he what's your name how old are
you
who's your grandma he answered him she
said facetime but i didn't have enough
uh bars to uh to uh let him do facetime
so i left it alone like that she said
okay
and then she said go check yourself into
metro or to a police department
i told you what i can't because i'm in
the middle of nowhere so my thought was
that was good enough i left it like that
we kept on traveling we get to a little
town when we get to this town
there was i was ambushed by all types of
law enforcement snipers
oh i mean you name it it was there
waiting for me
my kid was snatched for me the other kid
was daniel anything was snatched for me
my group
that i was with was detained and
arrested and everybody was under
arrest next you know i was
stripped down naked almost i can say
um we asked me questions where are my
kids where my kids why did i
murder my kids i'm like you have my kids
police asked you that yeah
well the person in charge of the police
officer
i'm like you have my kids you have i
kept on saying you have my kids
they were took it somewhere else i don't
know where they were took him at the
moment
and after that about an hour and a half
later
they were able to come back and we were
able to uh talk again
what time was this around because alerts
went out saturday morning and then what
time
were i guess um
when i called the first the first time
that i called that
carina cisneros was about around 11
11 between 11 and 12. got it and then
you realize that your face is all over
yeah i mean my mom was crying my my
family is texting me
turn yourself in my brother was trying
to find me
all the way to utah to uh to
fix his problem you know i'm saying what
was your initial reaction when you open
your phone you see all these like
notifications
and text messages and phone calls you
know waiting i was in disbelief like
i couldn't believe someone accused me
like this this is not this is not my
personality that's
that's not that's not me my sons know
that this is not me
this is why i'm doing it you know
because of my sons i want to go on me on
social media i want to
let people know that's not my style you
know i'm saying that's not my
that i mean i love my kids i do anything
for my kids that i mean this was for my
kids
we were camping for my kids
um your relationship with eden and
danny's mom they were really
you know quick to judge you um can you
talk about that relationship
all i have to say i mean i we have
communication for my kids i mean
i i respect them they respect me but
um i think they jumped the gun
they they know they knew they could have
done a different way and they know who
i am and they know that i will never
harm my kids
i can't speak for them because i don't
want to speak bad or good about them but
i'm not going to speak for them
but i can speak for myself that i will
never hurt my kids
you